[Musique]
simon morin bonjour bonjour shekau vous
êtes candidat donc aux élections
municipales dans la commune de saint
joseph vous le saviez très probablement
déjà mais enfin athanase jeanne rose
l'actuel maire de saint joseph pour
quelques semaines encore a déclaré le 25
janvier qu'il ne sera pas candidat à sa
propre succession donc il l'a confirmé
dix ans beaucoup de gens le supposait
déjà mais là c'est officiel et vous
voilà donc maintenant peut-être vous
simon morin définitivement soulagé je
sais pas si c'est le terme qui convient
non je suis pas forcément soulagé mais
monsieur le maire avait laissé entendre
il avait demandé une réflexion pour
prendre sa décision
et là je suppose mûrement réfléchi il a
mûrement pris sa décision après
l'édition ne pas se représenter
et cela je n'ai pas de commentaire
particulier
vous attendiez à autre chose peut-être
vous vous étiez aussi dans l'expectative
18 bat peut-être qu'il m'a forcément
nous ne pouvons pas nous ne pouvons pas
à prédire ce que le maire aurait fait
par rapport aux élections je suis son
premier adjoint depuis de mandature on
se connaît et il avait il avait ses
raisons personnelles à ne pas se
présenter
précisément simon morin le bilan de
votre mandature à votre groupe à votre
équipe politique municipale
ce bilan est-il entachée par les soucis
judiciaires qu'a connu le maire à tana
jeanne-rose leur un titre à titre
personnel évidemment mais chut
bien sûr je le dis et je le répète avec
force
c'est une affaire de loi privé cette
affaire privée
ça n'a rien à voir avec la gestion d'une
municipalité la gestion d'une
municipalité tout le monde sait que
lorsque vous prenez une décision au
conseil municipal
à partir du moment qu'il y a plein de
financement a fait qu'il y à des
décisions à prendre de ce côté saveurs
contrôle de la légalité
ça retourne au contrôle de la légalité
et si vous êtes au quai par rapport aux
textes favre vous l'appliquez ça n'a
absolument rien à voir avec la question
la réponse à ma question
vous répondez non si je vous demande le
bilan de votre mandature est-il entachée
par les soucis une chose à ciel ouvert
non non mais j'ai cru c'est l'amalgamé
que font certaines personnes pour vous
comprenez pour exploiter une situation
et c'est contre cela que je me bats
depuis longtemps alors qu'est ce que
vous avez à dire justement des six
dernières années qui se sont passées
puisque vous étiez le premier adjoint du
maire sortant
qu'est ce que vous mettez symboliquement
à l'actif de cette dernière mandature
alors de ces bolides manquer ce que je
peux mettre à l'actif de cette mandature
c'est que nous avons traversée de
mandature difficile difficile
financièrement comme beaucoup de
municipalités mais ce qui est à mon avis
très bien et qui traduit quand même une
certaine sérénité et puis la prise de
bonnes décisions
c'est que en 2015 2016 nous avions eu
des soubresauts financière et en 2017
nous avons redressé nous avons redresser
je le dis et au moins pour le
fonctionnement puisque effectivement il
faut le dire un faux le l'investissement
nous peinons nous peinons c'est
difficile parce que nous avons investi
beaucoup et jouer l'occasion de dire
pourquoi nous avons investi et
nommément nous avons peut-être pas assez
communiqué quand nous aurons pas
suffisamment communiqué mais nous avons
investi énormément et nous avons
effectivement eu nettement qu'elle nous
on imagine voilà vous mais un
endettement qui vous gêne mais vous
considérez que vous avez quand même au
moins partiellement assaini la situation
budgétaire
ah ben c'est ce que je crois qu'on tape
ce qu'est ce que je vous dis nous avons
pris des décisions difficiles un parfois
impopulaires mais nous avons eu le
courage politique parce qu'il faut avoir
du courage politique aussi un de prendre
ces décisions
vous avez une de vos ex colistière à la
députée manuela à quai car mon désir qui
se présentent également s de nature à
vous inquiéter
d'une manière ou d'une autre norman
houle a déclaré c'est une personne qui
qui a eu effectivement peut-être
candidate comme tout à chacun à la
travail d'un mois j'ai majorité
municipale était d'un autre majorité
municipale elle s'occupe aide des
travaux et des travaux s est pas occupé
un moment de sport culture et loisirs
aussi un moment nous ce qui me qui n'ont
qui me concerne avec une association
peut-être oui si on peut dire qu'elle
était présidente de l'office du tourisme
a été président de l'office de tourisme
cela vient elle avait fait son tracé au
travail week au service qu'elle a un
certain poids qu'elle a un certain poids
saint-joseph est
et qui plus est auréolé de son statut de
député maintenant mais écouter mais
aucun n'a pas renoncé c'est pourquoi
j'estime que tous les candidats ont du
poids 1 déjà pour se présenter il faut
il faut vouloir s'engager et ça c'est
déjà une bonne chose
1 le voilà engagé les autres parce que
nous aurions pu faire équipe ensemble
puisque deux adjoints qui se retrouve
l'un contre l'autre
non je suis pas contre maniaque éclats
comme je ne suis pas contre qui que ce
soit la démocratie donne la possibilité
la démocratie donne la possibilité de
nous présenter et tout chacun en deux
trois phrases je sais que l'exercice est
difficile mais si vous êtes élu c'est
mon amour un donc à la tête de la
municipalité de saint-joseph qu'est ce
que vous feriez en priorité en
municipalité et qui aurait mérité d'être
réalisés au cours des dernières
mandatures et qui n'a pas été fait vous
savez il ya des projets à court terme en
moyen long terme
à court terme nous avons des projets qui
décoder des projets importants qui
commence
mais les projets tournent
essentiellement sur les besoins de la
population
les bus les besoins le le le cadre de
vie et donc nous avons un gros projet
qui consiste à reprendre tout
l'éclairage public par exemple et nous
avons une convention une conventions
déjà signées où nous devons avancer un
apport une auto financement de l'armée
mais ça c'est ça mais pas ses acquis
c'est dans les tuyaux
oui c'est lui seul pourra démarrer très
vite merci simon morin ok
[Musique]